fans of the villain slash occasional
antihero Deathstroke are in for a treat
when they catch him in Justice League in
theaters Joe Manganiello who plays
Deathstroke has put together a pretty
respectable resume over his roughly two
decades in the film business but he's
not quite a household name just yet
here are a few reasons he looks so
familiar spider-man in 2002 spider-man
Manganiello played him from us bully
Eugene Flash Thompson he's horrible to
Peter Parker every opportunity to the
point where you can't help but cheer
when he finally gets what's coming to
him in the form of pizzas first Spider
powered beatdown How I Met Your Mother
the years after spider-man were pretty
lean for Manganiello who's been open
about the difficulties that followed his
first big break but eventually he landed
a recurring role on the hit sitcom How I
Met Your Mother
joining the cast in 2006 as Brad an old
law school friend of Jason Siegel's
character marshal Brad appeared in seven
episodes and took on a slightly more
antagonistic role in later seasons
causing drama with both Marshall and
Neil Patrick Harris as character Barney
One Tree Hill between 2008 and 2010 CW
melodrama One Tree Hill gave Manganiello
his most significant TV role up to that
point he joined the show as Owen a bar
manager who strikes up a romance with
series star Sofia bushes character
Brooke and appeared in 12 episodes over
the course of three seasons True Blood
Manganiello next appeared as Alcide a
hunky werewolf who showed up in the
third season of HBO's vampire drama True
Blood Alcide is a fun favorite character
from the books that inspired the show
and a Manganiello nailed it in 42
episodes thanks to his natural night-sky
charm and well what he looks like with
our show
not news to anyone white-collar season
three of the USA Network's white-collar
saw Manganiello sign on for a one
episode guest appearance which features
him in an antagonistic role has been the
neighbor of series regular Tiffani
Thiessen's character Elizabeth it was
the first time in awhile Manganiello
played a full-fledged villain experience
that would come in handy a few years
later when he landed the role of
Deathstroke Magic Mike Manganiello
combination of charm and killer physique
clearly got him the right kind of
attention from director Steven
Soderbergh who cast him in a memorable
supporting role in his 2012 smash hit
dramedy Magic Mike Manganiello appears
in the film was a heartthrob dancer with
a memorable name his go-to costume a
classic fireman gets up funny enough he
almost didn't take the role and it was
Chris Rock of all people who convinced
him to do it if I don't get a shirt on
soon every guy in the world's gonna hate
my guts and Chris said man they're gonna
hate your guts anyway
sabotage end of watch director David
Ayer custom angin ello and sabotage
starring guard Oates Watson eager
Manganiello plays Grindr a character
mostly recognizable due to his distinct
cornrows sabotage didn't go over too
well with critics and was ultimately a
box-office failure but it does feature
some killer action sequences and lots of
big guys blowing stuff up which is kind
of all you want from a movie like this
Magic Mike XXL Richey returned in the
2015 follow-up to Magic Mike
coyly titled Magic Mike XXL with the
original film's Alex Pettyfer and
Matthew McConaughey not returning for
the sequel Manganiello saw a
significantly larger amount of screen
time in this one Ricci is also the
centerpiece of what is almost indecisive
the film when he performs an impromptu
striptease set - I want it that way by
the Backstreet Boys right in the middle
of the empty mini-mart who wish for
chillers water
Hughie's big holiday Manganiello
appeared in another hilarious role soon
after the Magic Mike sequel playing a
fictionalized version of himself in 2016
s pee-wee's big holiday and like many
cameo roles in which celebs play
themselves Manganiello is actually a
pretty central character over the course
of the movie Manganiello plays himself
as a perfect caricature over-the-top
macho but quietly still a goofy little
kid at heart thanks appreciate that
thanks for watching click the Lupo icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you're lifting
[Music]